benjamin à ma professeure d'histoire
porte parole de la cgt
dans le val de marne à ses côtés yves
buisson membre de l'académie de médecine
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être là
pour réagir donc à ce plan de
déconfinement d'edouard philippe
notamment sur cette question des écoles
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler souvent
avec vos benjamin amar la première
question est pour vous le premier
ministre qui a tenté de se montrer
rassurant lors déjà pas une ouverture
stricte ans au sens propre à partir du
11 mai pour tout le monde c'est très
progressif
certains d'ailleurs ils vont pour leurs
frêles et les lycéens ne verront pas
l'école avant le mois de juin et encore
la décision n'est pas prise le 18 mai
pour les collégiens mais ça dépendra des
départements vous êtes satisfait ou
encore déçu benjamin a maintenant je
suis surtout je constate que le
gouvernement vous savez à un peu la même
attitude que charles vanel et yves
montand dans le salaire de la peur c'est
le gouvernement de la main qui tremble
il ya des déclarations fracassantes et
puis ensuite quand on sent qu'à une
levée de boucliers lorsque les parents
d'élèves les enseignants effectivement
montent au créneau via le gouvernement
essaye d'organiser le rétropédalage
et là on a finalement eu une une
situation où gouvernement donne
l'impression de postuler au championnat
européen david à cet effet vous le
vouliez serait en europe et dallages
alors mais on a un gouvernement qui
effectivement et tentera de faire
progressivement machine arrière mais ça
devient ubuesque
par exemple on vous dit que les lycées
ne reprendront pas enfants avant le mois
de juin qu'est ce à dire
on va donc quand même essayer de voir si
en juin on peut ouvrir et faire cours
dans les lycées
encore une fois l'alpha et l'oméga c'est
les conditions de sécurité sanitaire
c'est à dire où on en est du point de
vue des masques où on en est du point de
vue des tests la question elle est là le
gouvernement nous dit on va faire des
petits groupes
mais bon sang ce gouvernement il est
4h02 d'agrandir les murs comme par magie
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il y a campus
ya l'argument qui est pris l'argument
des décrocheurs en nous disant mais
voilà
c'est indispensable pour leur scolarité
ce gouvernement si vous voulez je peux
vous dire depuis trois ans à quel point
ils liquident tous les moyens de lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire voilà donc
là on est dans une position de tartuffe
encore une fois il y à la pression du
patronat est donc derrière il faut
essayer de voir comment est ce qu'on
fait garder les enfants
quand on voit quand on compare avec les
autres clusters moi je ne suis pas
médecin mais par contre j'ai des yeux
pour voir et des oreilles pour entendre
lorsque on constate que dans les autres
foyers comparable à la france je ne
parle pas de la norvège ou la suède
je parle de l'espagne de l'italie de
l'état de new york on nous dit à la
rentrée c'est en septembre elle est
reportée si didier et c'est en septembre
et bien voilà quelque chose qui est
frappés au sceau du bon sens ce
gouvernement est inconséquent et il en
est il ils pratiquent l'incertitude
permanente les choses sont simples il
faut reporter la rentrée en septembre
moi je suis propre je suis rentrée dans
l'enseignement pour lutter contre les
inégalités scolaires et mes collègues
font la même chose c'est notre notre
mission chevillée au corps
et lorsque ce gouvernement qui encore
une fois liquide régulièrement les
moyens de l'école républicaine nous dit
qu'aujourd'hui il s'intéresse
il met au dessus de tout le décrochage
scolaire franchement ça donne envie de
rire est plutôt pleurer
en réalité il ya quelque chose qui au
dessus qui s'applique s'il a la parole
aux médecins de lisier voilà je ne suis
pas médecin
ça tombe d'anyama à vos côtés ils lui
sont membres de l'académie de médecine
est ce que vous vous partager entre
guillemets la sévérité de benjamin a
marre oui il fallait y aller franchement
est reporté tout simplement le retour à
l'école en septembre selon vous non j'ai
pas du tout la même position il faut
dire que je ne suis pas d'enseignants du
moins pas en saignant au niveau scolaire
ou collèges ou lycées
donc je n'ai pas fait la même vision des
choses une vision de médecin je
considère effectivement que
il est difficile de les confiner de
toute façon le choix qui a été fait est
un choix qui respecte deux paramètres le
premier c'est celui de l'âge
et effectivement les classes d'âge les
plus venez plus petites sont les classes
d'âge où les enfants sont le moins
touché par le comique 19 font les formes
les moins la plus généralement
asymptomatiques ou très très peu très
peu graves et surtout sont très
faiblement transmetteur ceci est bien
établie et sakho et ça va jusqu'à à peu
près l'âge du primaire inclut donc cette
première réserve est tout à fait prise
en compte dans la progressivité la
deuxième c'est le fait que on va d
confiné d'abord dans les départements
qui ont été les moins touchés par
l'épidémie ce qui est logique ce qui est
conforme aux recommandations nous avions
fait nous on avait envisagé ou le niveau
régional mais il est certain que le
niveau départemental et encore lui
permet une plus grande adaptabilité une
plus grande souplesse dans les décisions
donc globalement je moi je ne suis pas
en désaccord avec les décisions qui ont
été annoncés pour ce qui concerne le
déconfinement scolaire alors je vais
vous faire écouter le dpt à debout la
france nicolas dupont aignan pour lui le
plan de déconfinement prévue avec le
retour à l'école et incohérent des
millions d'enfants vont être rassemblés
dans des classes sans masque sans
masquer les enfants qui ont le plus de
mal à voir des gestes barrières alors on
nous explique que les français doit être
raisonnable ils n'auront pas le droit
d'aller sur une plage ils n'auront pas
le droit de se rassembler à plus de 10
on leur demande
on dormait d'énormes contraintes ils
n'auront pas le droit de se déplacer
d'un département à un autre et puis en
même temps on va rassembler des millions
d'enfants dans des classes pour faire
bouillon de culture mais c'est une honte
je voterai contre ceux des confinement
car nicolas dupont aignan qui étaient
tous d'accord avec vous benjamins à marc
edouard philippe a néanmoins donné des
gages conditions sanitaires strictes 15
élèves par classe des masques évidemment
pour les enseignants est ce que sur ce
point tout de même vous êtes rassurés
alors d'abord excusé moi
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide le
l'histoire des masques on nous dit que
20 millions de masques seront là dans
quinze jours
ça fait des mois qu'on attend t on nous
dit qu'on va tester sept cent mille
personnes par semaine à peu près ce que
c'est le chiffre qui a été avancé alors
qu'on sait que où on est complètement à
la ramasse du point de vue des tests on
est complètement en retard par rapport à
certains de nos voisins donc excusez moi
on jugera sur les faits et encore une
fois le l'alpha et l'oméga de la cgt
s'est pas de protection pas travail
c'est à dire que ce qui conditionne le
retour des activités c'est la manière
dont on garantit concrètement les codis
les conditions de la sécurité de la
santé publique maintenant j'entendais à
ce que disait monsieur mais d'abord je
tiens à rappeler que dans les classes il
n'y a pas que les élèves
il ya également des enseignants et je ne
suis pas médecin tout à fait j'ai bien
compris que les enfants ou les
adolescents pouvait effectivement être
porteur de la maladie sans en avoir les
symptômes donc
excusez-moi de m'intéresser en tant que
syndicaliste à la santé de mes collègues
ensuite moi j'ai été victime de cette
maladie sous sa forme grave et je n'ai
aucune garantie aujourd'hui le corps
médical ne peux pas me dire si je peux
recontre à recontacter la maladie une
deuxième fois à quel niveau et dans
quelle durée je peux bénéficier d'une
immunité
donc ça c'est des questions très
importantes en réalité on s'est bien
rendu compte que depuis le début il ya
une armée énorme aimant de choses qu'on
ne sait pas sur cette maladie
on tâtonne comme des aveugles dans le
noir ils découvrent des choses tous les
jours je lisais un article
comme quoi en angleterre les sein du nhs
se sont rendus compte qu une maladie qui
présente un certain nombre de points
communs avec le communisme
frappe particulièrement les enfants et
que c'est apparu depuis quelques
semaines et il ya également des cas en
espagne en italie dans la moi je ne fais
aucune conclusion hâtive mais toutefois
voilà je remarque qu'il ya plein de
choses qu'on ne sait pas sur cette
maladie tv je veux marquer pendant des
mois que ce ne va pas vendre tant sur
des produits terminé en allemagne on a
fait un des confirmands un peu précoce
et on se rend compte qu'il ya une
résurgence de la maladie et le risque
d'une deuxième vague pire que la
première
tout le monde devrait être un petit peu
prudent et humble dans cette histoire
ils lui sont alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de confusion avec cette
histoire d'enfant vecteurs ou non au
début on les considérait comme ultra
vecteur on comparer ça à la grippe
effectivement avec le temps on s'est
rendu compte qu'ils le sont - benjamin
marc nous parle de voilà de cet article
par avant dans la presse britannique
quel est votre point de vu de médecin
sur ce point est ce que vous admettez
une forme de confusion au contraire vous
vous estimez aujourd'hui qu'on vous voit
de plus en plus clair avec les enfants
ne sont pas si dangereux oui où on sait
de plus en plus on ne sait pas tout
d'une entendu on encore brut choses à
découvrir
mais pour ce qui concerne l'effective
mans la gravité de l'infection c'est
l'enfance ce ce sont des choses des
connaissances maintenant de plus en plus
certaine de plus bien établi de même que
sur la capacité des petits enfants et
les deux enfants jeunes de moins de 10
ans du 6 à 12 ans à transmettre le virus
faible faible capacité de transmission
donc il est bien évident qu'on pense
seulement aux enfants on pense bien
entendu aux enseignants aux personnels
scolaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
adultes doivent porter un masque
non pas pour se protéger mais parce que
eux sont peut-être contaminateur et
risque de disséminer le virus au sein de
leurs coûts parce que sa fille ne les
collégiens porter de masque est votre
réaction c'est une bonne décision des
autorités les conditions devront porter
le masque est ce qu'on peut porter
choses correctement à 10 ans on est
encore petit disent on est tout à fait
capable de porter un masque on est
capable de fermer ses chaussures il est
là c'est donc il n'ya pas de différence
ça s'apprend très très vite c'est très
facile et d'ailleurs
ce que les enseignants pourront en
profiter pour enseigner la façon de
porter le masque que la façon de se
laver les mains correctement la façon
d'utiliser le gel hydroalcoolique la
façon de respecter les règles d'hygiène
de base
lorsque très souvent les enfants ne
n'ont pas reçu cette éducation cet
enseignement au milieu familial et je
pense que l'école là ce peut saisir
cette occasion de rattraper des lacunes
dans les familles lesquelles l'hygiène
est un peu négligé et je vois que
benjamin a marre brouillonne alors des
dernières soyez rapide s'il vous plaît
benjamin moore je voulais vous faire
réagir sur un dernier point important
parce que c'est ça file et le
volontariat alors ça c'est vrai que les
parents
merci pour les parents ils ont en gros
la responsabilité oui ou non d'envoyer
ou pas leurs enfants sur un terrain
dangereux ou non
quelle est votre réaction sur ce point
oui alors je fais de la tête parce que
autant moi je ne me permettrais pas de
donner des conseils professionnels à
monsieur buisson autant visiblement dans
l'huile anctil a on peut en faire aux
enseignants c'est l'écouté je l'invite
donc oui oui non mais non mais j'insiste
cela s'est passé ça ensuite son
volontariat écoutez il ya beaucoup de
parents d'élèves ya des associations de
parents d'élèves qui ont dit clairement
qu'elle était opposée à ceux des
confinement moi j'ai beaucoup de gens
dans mon entourage qui effectivement
disent qu ils ne mettront pas leurs
enfants à l'école je pense que ça va
être assez massif et quant aux
enseignants parce que les enseignants ça
compte aussi
je pense qu'on va voir comment ça se
profile on va voir comment ça se définit
en intersyndicale
mais le droit de retrait comme le droit
de grève vont à mon avis être des
options largement utilisé 800 sur ce
volontariat vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est compliqué de donner la
responsabilité finalement aux parents
non je pense que les parents eux s'ils
veulent s'informer ils peuvent
s'informer sur la nature des risques
je pense que il faut qu'il faut informer
les parents pour qu'ils informent leurs
enfants que les enfants comprennent bien
qu'on ne va pas les envoyer dans un
endroit où vous aiguiller les cours des
dangers de
d'infection etc il faut que justement
c'est il ya beaucoup de formation
d'information à donner de la pédagogie
m'excuse d'utiliser ce terme qui n'est
pas qui est réservée normalement aux
milieux scolaires mais c'est le moment
d'en faire ça passe par les parents
notamment les parents qui devront aller
chercher leur enfant à la sortie des
classes devront éviter de s'agglutiner
un seul parent par enfant respectez les
distances iations sociale et porter le
masque bien entendu merci merci à tous
les deux benjamin a marre ils lui seront
d'avoir été avec moi pour réagir donc
notamment sur cette question du retour à
l'école